the environmental movements is so
fascinating to me because it's
increasingly this Coalition of I guess
techno optimists like yourself but also
basically anti-capitalist greens and
you've even penned a piece I'm going to
pull up here it's speaking to that
audience it's in the Atlantic what many
progressives misunderstand about climate
change
what is your message to that side of the
environmentalist coalition
yeah I think it's really just about
keeping our eye on the ball and so I I
wrote that piece for the Atlantic based
on what an environmental activist said
in a rolling stone article that uh they
didn't like certain climate Solutions
because certain large corporations like
Exxon might benefit from carbon capture
technology or yeah like Elon Musk with
Tesla might benefit if we switch to
electric vehicles and
the point of that piece I wrote in the
Atlantic was really just
taking the idea of climate change
seriously as an emergency and not even
it's not even debate like whether it is
or isn't just like if you assume it is
if you're the person in the
environmental Community who activism
Community who says all the time that
climate change is an emergency that I
want to take that seriously so what
would that mean what would that entail
to treat it as an emergency and in my
experience in my opinion treating
something like an emergency means
keeping a laser focus on a mission that
would actually solve that emergency and
end the crisis and so for client for
global climate change it's this is an
emissions problem and so we should be
pretty agnostic about who we partner
with as long as that you know is
something that actually benefits the
climate and actually works towards
solving the problem and so I think I'm
also pushing back against there's this
term that some of the environmental
actors of community love called like
fake Solutions like those are fake
solutions to climate crisis and I don't
even really think of real solutions
there just are solutions or there aren't
um is this a kind of return to the like
the more technocratic idea of actually
we're going to literally like measure
or create some sort of proxy or
something to measure how much carbon is
being put out and then do you know I
don't know cap and trade or carbon
credits or something like that because
that's more of a agnostic you know
energy agnostic solution you know
something like nuclear under the right
regulatory conditions might be able to
compete on in that world versus the
world we're in now where it's much more
tax break and subsidy based
yes I think that's like that's one
version of this um that's definitely the
one that vast majority of economists
would endorse is some kind of you know
first best is carbon tax a very close
second best is cap and trade because
there's basically economically
equivalent depending on how they're
designed and then you know second and
third best are things like subsidies
um we also try to be quite politically
pragmatic in our work at ifp in
Washington we're working in Washington
DC and so as of now and has been the
case in recent decades carbon taxes and
similar programs are extremely
politically unpopular and most elected
officials are aware of this fact and so
anything that increases the cost of
energy we saw you over the last few
years the gas the crisis over gas prices
and how much that hurt uh popularity of
the incumbent president and I think
um actually implementing those seems
extremely unlikely no I think that's the
case where second best Solutions like
some of the subsidies we see for clean
energy Technologies make a lot of sense
and then Zach you and I can talk more
about like how we can Implement those
subsidies in a more efficient way that
you know limits the downsides of picking
winners and losers but I think we're
working within that bucket and we're
probably not in a carbon tax World
unfortunately I wanted to ask a slightly
nerdy question uh from your Atlantic
article in the Atlantic you write
um some environmentalists are skeptical
of geothermal energy which requires
extensive drilling yet it has high
potential as a source of clean base load
power with the small geographical
footprint that can in theory be deployed
anywhere in the world if you drill deep
enough one way to accelerate investment
in geothermal energy would be to give
this clean technology the same expedited
permitting that oil and gas companies
already receive for leases on Federal
Land where is the opposition to that
coming from like for for my little
libertarian heart clearing the path of
regulations and treating a geothermal
drilling company the same way he would
uh you know treat other people in that
space or other companies in that space
that's an obvious thing why do people
oppose this yeah so it says there's
opposition on both sides and I wouldn't
say that the majority of each party or
each each part of the Coalition but
they're loud enough and this is a
neglected under the radar issue of like
how is geothermal versus oil and gas
permitted under the National
Environmental Policy Act it's a very
wonky question that doesn't get a lot of
attention
um but there's enough opposition to you
know keep us in the current status quo
and not let reform happen yet and so on
the left the similarities in fracturing
so even though geothermal is about
capturing natural heat resources using
that to heat up water turn into steam
it's been a turbine there's no fossil
fuels in this process the fact that
involves fracturing into the Earth
um makes a lot of more conservationists
than I would say climate folks concerned
and so they're they're opposed often to
things
in terms of geothermal and I would add
that
um the advantage that oil and gas has is
they have a categorical exclusion for
exploration projects on Federal Land
categorically excluded from NEPA the
National Environmental Policy Act okay
and a lot of the environmental
communities just like they are across
the board opposed to categorical
exclusions they just think any kind of
you know carving out carve out of the
process whether it's clean is there
solar wind geothermal
fossil fuels obviously like they just
don't want to be carving out from that
law because they view it as kind of
sacrosanct okay that's the left
opposition and the right opposition I
would say it's more just like uh oil and
gas has the current advantage and so
they don't want to give subsidies to a
new industry and there's a lot of on the
right right wing of the spectrum there's
skepticism Around clean technology in
general and so they prefer to maintain
the the current Sasso that favors oil
and gas just really fast to follow up
you've written a little bit about how
NEPA very much empowers people to stymie
these different projects it reminds me a
little bit of our colleague Christian
birchkey's reporting on sequa uh which
is you know weaponized by the nimbies of
California to stop all kinds of
developments but you know nipa's much
broader and you know you write about how
it gives enormous power to people to um
block Innovative new projects could you
just like give us a sense of like a few
of the problems with that really fast
yes I think the key thing is for any
large or medium-sized project they're
going to be
some losers you know even if project
benefits 99 of the community maybe one
person who lives near a transmission
line doesn't want the transition line
right over right next to their backyard
and like I'm actually kind of somewhat
sympathetic to that claim of like that
is a nuisance that is you know a cost
can be an eyesore for you know big
infrastructure projects but I think the
key is these things need to be built
somewhere
um and you know we need to be doing
projects that we can get as much
consensus on as possible we can't wait
for 100 perfect consensus because you
almost will never get that and so when
you have a tool like NEPA and the key
thing is that it allows people to sue
the government if the environmental
review was incomplete in any measure by
incomplete we mean has it considered
every potential environmental impact and
the way this law has evolved over the
last 50 years is the term environment
and impact have just been defined more
and more and more broadly and it's kind
of the same possible problem to solve
where like the documents are currently
you know often more than a thousand
pages long but they can always be longer
they'll always be one more thing you
didn't consider right and so it's a very
low bar to clear in your lawsuit you
don't need to say that this harms the
environment you don't need to say that
it's you know violates the Clean Water
Act or the Clean Air Act those
substantive standards you just need to
say you didn't consider this one
potential impact
um and then if you can you know prove
that case in court the court can issue
an injunction against the project and
stop it they send the review back to the
agency for another multi-year you know
addendum to the original review and that
just stops the dead in the tracks and
then often the the tactic here is delay
delay delay to just keep challenging it
in court until the developer is like I'm
broke or the bank pulled my funding I
can't do this project anymore it's funny
these are these like wonky
environmentalist hecklers videos
essentially you see us with sequel you
see this with NEPA and it's a story you
know time and time again and it seems
like it's getting worse over time not
better
yeah it's it's absolutely reached a
crisis Point that's why you hear more
and more about permitting reform in
Washington DC and that like like your
colleague it's also a state level issue
because many states have their own
environmental procedure laws but I think
the key thing for the audience to know
is that
um we should be pretty positive about
environmentally
um environmental substance laws like the
Clean Air Act and clean water they're
not perfect but when you have an
objective standard of like this is what
your product is allowed to you know
affect the air affect the water that's a
much better standard than these
procedural roles that say you have to
comprehensively consider every potential
impact
um I think that's the kind of thing we
need to get back towards in like this
proceduralism has run amok at this point
hey thanks for watching that excerpt
from our conversation with Alex Stop of
the institute for progress about
operation warp speed the Trump
Administration plan to accelerate
development of covid-19 vaccines if you
liked it you can watch the full
interview right here or another clip
right here